الليلة
، قيل لطفلاً صغيرًا في إلينوي إنه لن يعيش بعد
عيد ميلاده الثاني ، ألقِ نظرة على هذه
[الموسيقى]
اللطيفة جدًا لدرجة أن ناش ستينمان بلغ
الثالثة من عمره هذا الأسبوع للاحتفال بمدينته وألقى
به عرضًا مناسبًا
لبطل  هي ذراعي والدة ناش حيث تم
تكريمه من قبل مجموعة ضخمة من
الشاحنات والسيارات والحافلات ، ويعاني ناش من
مرض عصبي عضلي نادر يعرف
بالذكاء ويضعف جهازه
المناعي ويمنعه من التواجد
حول الكثير من الناس لأنه لم يستطع
الحصول على  حفلة عيد ميلاد نموذجية
انضم إليها المجتمع معًا
واحتفل على الطريق كما ترى ،
كان هناك إقبال كبير على إلقاء نظرة على
جميع أصدقاء السيارات
ورجال الإطفاء وغيرهم جميعًا
ظهروا لإظهار ناش كم أحب
أحد الأشياء التي نوعا ما.  لقد
فقدت جزء التفاعل
الاجتماعي ، وبسبب هذا العرض
والدعم من مجتمعنا
، تم ملء هذه القطعة ، قيل لي إنه لن
يتمتع أبدًا بأي جودة في الحياة  هذا
هو أبعد ما يكون عن الحقيقة ، حيث
تقول والدته بريتني إن ناش
يواصل تحدي الصعاب على الرغم من
عدم وجود علاج لمرضه في الوقت
الحالي ، فقد بدأت مؤسسة غير ربحية لجمع
الأموال من أجل الأبحاث الجينية مثل ناش
وتقويم الحياة وسط  المصاعب التي يواجهها
هنا هي هذا الطفل الصغير الذي
يبلغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات والذي يمر
بصراع لا يمكن لمعظمنا
أن يفهمه على الإطلاق ، وبطريقة ما
تمكن من القيام بذلك بابتسامة كاملة
على وجهه كل يوم ، لذا
فهذه هي الطريقة التي يلهمها  أنا أعلم أن الكثير من
الناس يشعرون بنفس الطريقة التي يشعر بها أنه
مصدر إلهام بشكل لا يصدق لذكر تعامل عمره ثلاث سنوات
مع كل هذا
وبابتسامة إنه أمر لا يصدق